hello and welcome to this video playing
Brady 64 a slob episode g4 it's one of
the two main lines okay so I'm not
getting my bishop pair he like this but
like this um okay huh how does that work
Lego Bishop g2 but which I would like to
do then c4 is hanging and the queen
queen bee three then G for us hanging
what what is this house is played ng5
maybe we're fat to lose let's see okay
just goes back for 97 to f5 yes hmm okay
i think with hindsight bishop t2 wasn't
the most clever move ever but maybe it's
i don't know i'm not a huge expert IAM
so is e 5 a move but i think teshon i
can also just take him
hmm that's definitely definitely there's
some risk involved with this queen queen
bee three for example on between e7
print screen takes beasts on rupee aid
Quincy 6mm sure it might work well but I
won't have it some kind of theoretic
line because he has played it so quickly
but people tend to play super committal
moves very quickly ok I think I just go
t5 taking us is bad and I don't see how
I can let him take so I'm not happy with
d5 but I probably have to do it and well
it's not like he's got an easy game here
the night on g8 is stuck and it's not
not totally clear how he coordinates his
position him
hmm it's not easy for black you also
cannot castle i will take c6 take f7 I
has to defend very precisely not quite
sure what is move this to be honest
something creative Luke age 44 f for
giving the exchange gain the e5 square
yeah we'll see yeah and always taking
the time but if I've was played
instantly which is the cause for this
position it happens by force
yeah okay I was just thinking that this
might be the way to go okay see going
for see for him interesting kingo a4 a5
not sure about it though let's let's go
for it playing on the queenside with his
King side and developed this is probably
interesting okay I was thinking a five
but we'll see he has to take on be three
more or less then i take p 6 I take a
seven and a half night be five that was
my idea attacking be three
n95 was my idea and then be three hangs
all doing that while as i said the rukon
age 8 and the night on g8 is not doing
much ok so here I can check g6 take be
three
let's see how good that is but check
it's a porn at least
you might have 97 though finally getting
the night out hmm yeah wonder if Bishop
before is correct here or queen a form
tween a for he has to move the king with
the rook is already doing something
that's not that bad
jay is still king of eight
king of Aden probably just Bishop e3
keeping the porn
oh the bishop before I am picture before
it's a move Bishop before Queen to be
six there is between a three that's
actually its strong as d 67 is also a
threat so this is a good move i think
Queen B 6 between a three and I don't
see how we cover c7
Quincy 76 Roxy 76 rupee 86 for d7 check
you probably will do some Hail Mary move
like windy form we just say yeah we know
the deal Jack still have to have to be
alert him and c naught naught to blunder
everything so before is this is a pretty
substantial threat how the line one who
do a cover things this may be let's
rooks it for Queen III
it could be to be wanting something like
that
castle church books III still not super
easy
between before cream before many black
forfeits on time before is a draw now AM
Jam here here it's still precision I
mean it's a it's a win + 3 or cool but
it's still still tough with no time on
the clock I still have it here but I
have to go h4 after this is to draw it's
really a draw amazing the actual check I
was thinking here with rook b3 is even
winning so I have to do this check this
and it's a small okay but let's have a
look at the at the game this is from the
theoretical position and I don't know
Bishop t2 maybe g5 immediately something
like that yeah he he pled the very
committal movie 5 instantly almost and
get it should loses actually queen bee
three wins for what but I couldn't I
couldn't figure that out completely I
thought this this queen bee seven loopy
yups not this loopy eight takes takes
and it wasn't clear to me as Knight e5
sometimes might happen and 95 I
calculated the status doesn't work but
the engine gives this and says I'm
winning okay yeah it's all possible one
thing that I did not really see us after
26 that this is never move with the pin
and it wants to do this and says plus 3
m now if I've that that this is a bad
movies well you play the black instantly
but it just opens up Mikey p.m. so
yeah tween f3x queen bee three I
couldn't figure out correctly and here
it's better but it's nothing nothing
special yeah like a plus one a form yeah
see for I can also go back but I thought
a five is interesting and it needs to
advantage here 9 p-5 and Chang ya hear
the check computer instead wants to just
castle or walking f1 yeah it's a clean
pawn and the protected person and not
only seven Silver's not good but this is
this is winning of course d 6 is even
stronger uh-huh now because the 94
counter place don't work I only saw this
but Jan here it's it's also winning over
piece but it's still a little bit murky
and here probably here castles and just
Castle him I was thinking this might be
an issue though but the computer finds
this and this is clarifying things
nicely I have this thread hmm ok thanks
for watching